five years ago he helped to point her
and tonight he effectively sacked her
the first woman to leave the uk's
largest force ending a 40-year policing
career in failure following contact with
the mayor of london today
it is quite clear that the mayor no
longer has sufficient confidence in my
leadership
of the metropolitan police service
for me to continue as commissioner
he has left me no choice but to step
aside
i say this with deep sadness
and regret she submitted a plan for
reform but the mayor rejected it last
week i made clear to the metropolitan
police commissioner
the scale of the change i believe
is urgently required
to rebuild the trust and confidence of
londoners in the met
and to root out the racism
sexism
homophobia
bullying
discrimination and misogyny that still
exists
i am not satisfied with the
commissioner's response
on being informed of this
dame crescendo dick has offered her
resignation
which i have accepted
her start in the job was marked with
tragedy on her very first day she
attended the funeral of pc keith palmer
who had been murdered in the westminster
terrorist attack no sarah i don't know
the kidnap rape and murder of sarah
everard by a serving met officer
prompted questions not just about the
vetting of staff but a culture in parts
of the force of misogyny
[Applause]
and the commissioner was further
criticized when a vigil for sarah
everard was broken up by police due to
covert rules one of those arrested said
tonight the mayor has made the right
decision of course i'm pleased i think a
lot of families are as well families
that have dealt with like their family
members dying in police custody under
her reign um all sorts of things that
have happened during her being the head
of the the met um i think what we need
to focus on though as well is that this
not be a token gesture you know this
doesn't fix anything and i just hope
that whoever's in charge next
understands that radical change needs to
be implemented i really thought she was
going to bring in a a real ethical
leadership a real understanding of
accountability and transparency and not
double down on what's going on but in in
in the end we saw that she was saying
well she doesn't recognize institutional
sexism she doesn't recognize
institutional racism and in fact she
started become like a blocker she was
part of the problem not part of the
solution
chaos and violence at the final of the
european championships was also blamed
on poor policing
in december a pair of officers were
jailed for taking photos of two murder
victims which they shared on whatsapp
and after resisting pressure to
investigate downing street parties
shortly before su gray was due to report
the met changed its mind there was
evidence that those involved knew
or ought to have known
that what they were doing was an offence
but it seems the final straw was a
damning report last week from the police
watchdog about a toxic culture of racism
sexism and homophobia at a london police
station there had been jokes about rape
people with disabilities and references
to the holocaust and yet in an
organization with 40 000 employees
change is difficult and slow
and some argue the departure of dame
cressler dick will damage morale here
yet further
the way that the commissioner has been
treated is a disgrace and worse than
the treatment of her i think it's left
londoners less safe
it will leave the metropolitan police
less stable and it will
certainly not speed the process of
change that we all accept is entirely
necessary
bringing in a new person
inevitably will delay that process of
change
as mayor of london both boris johnson
and sadiq khan have now forced out a
mech commissioner
it is an ominous president as the search
for a successor begins joe pike sky news
new scotland yard